and this is the moment tactic time now
the position it's already too loose ears
too loose so it's time for to find a
tactical shot here to win the game now
now you're going for the victory here
[Music]
okay all right guys we're gonna start so
this is the advanced class and please
take your seats everybody and please
let's be very focused okay guys so we're
gonna start that by going over this game
and this game is played by Bobby Fischer
Robert Fischer the only American world
champion and he played a move Knight f3
Knight f6 g3 so what I was gonna say is
the red tee okay it's a ready opening
okay so Fischer played that sometimes
and this is in a US Open Oklahoma City
long time ago he played this game it's a
really nice win d5 Bishop g2 you develop
the Bishop Bishop f5 Castle so again why
it is not aiming for any big advantage
it just wants to get the pieces out and
castle to get to safety
white black place is six now
when the bishop is usually here we don't
really want to play d5 because the
bishop is gonna be too strong so we want
to try to play d3 that's what you want
to play d3 to blockade the bishop okay
and d3
now a bishop is blocked Bishop is
blocked cannot do anything now he plays
c6
night bd2 1982 with the idea to play
efore at some point to prepare maybe for
idea okay 986 we see now he played a
tree controlling this before square and
at some point he would like to play the
move before himself to play like before
and put the [ __ ] boom [ __ ] be 295 now
is it a good idea to play before here
don't rush is it a good idea to play
this move what do you think he didn't
play the move what night can go what do
you think he can go yes huh no not b3 b3
I can take night has a very good square
here he can go to yes d7 is a normal
square but something more active you
have something more active here more
active let's see yes yes yes night a for
look at that square now coming to c3 9
goes to c3 attacking the Queen very very
nice okay so that's why he didn't want
to play that okay when he plays before
he wants to make sure the piece is gonna
go back it's not gonna go forward okay
so he played c4 and now if you play the
move before it's fine because the knight
can I go here you will take it okay he
cannot do that any longer so he played B
5 but this before is not the best move
because it weakens the position in
particular it weakens upon which pawn
did weaken now this move before
which pondered a weaken every pawn move
you push you weaken something right what
did he weaken yes yes you weaken c6 yes
you weaken c6 the pawn on c6 is weak now
right and now you're gonna try to attack
it and how did Fischer attack this pawn
immediately with the move he activates a
piece and attacks he activates an
attacks let's see here lots of hands we
see here lots of hands yes what did he
play n d4 Knight to D for bringing the
night here and now look at this directly
attacking the pawn on c6 directly now
this pawn is under attack
okay how about this now training mode so
you don't see it and attacking the that
is excellent thinking yes so this is a
cold fork right now he play Queen d7 to
protect c6 which now what is what can
you do now what can you take
what can you take here that is going to
ruin Bucks position
you
yeah like this thank you he takes and
now look at the pawns are doubled your
light square Bishop is now very nice
here on this diagonal so really black is
in big trouble
now it laid an IB 393 trying to trade
the Knights okay and opening up the
bishop to go to okay Bishop go to g5
that's what you want to do trade a
little bit and go Bishop g5 so it played
h6 trying to control the g5 square so no
Bishop g5 Bishop e3 he activates and
attacking the rook
so the attacking the knight he takes
if he takes Queen takes
and again lots of pressure on d5 on b5
this Bishop is very strong this is why
you see the two bishops are very strong
especially when a position is going to
get open like this okay
96
Knight d4 trading the Knights
g6 and Queen b3 activating the Queen
putting lots of pressure now on b5 on d5
so he played rook b8 now what can you do
here what I think white can play here
a big big advantage for white he has
much better development and then look at
black king is still in the middle Bishop
is here
Lara pieces are still not developed here
yes he took on c6 now you attacking the
rook
now the rock is under attack so he has
to take it
and now you want to try to fork do you
see the fork now you can take something
and fork okay what can you do a fork yes
Tigran excellent now you're attacking
the Queen and night now he played Knight
c5 now if you take the Queen he's
planning to take back the Queen here
with a knight and if you take with the
bishop here he's gonna take back with
the Queen so here you actually need a
quiet move okay you need a quiet move
here quiet move that will basically win
the game
the game ended in just few more moves
here what move did he play here yes yeah
yeah but if you do that he takes your
queen to you take the Queen he takes o
Queen torso so you need something else
something else needed here yes no these
six but what if I go now Queen takes G
to check and then I take the Queen at
the end okay all right
no he doesn't want to lose his Queen
here he wants to keep the Queen he wants
to keep the Queen yes you gun
interesting move Arab to see what but he
still takes the Queen yeah
then you won't take with this yeah yeah
I mean this is a White has a very strong
position White has a very strong
position here but not immediately
winning okay big advantage it's a big
advantage here what else what else we
can do if we want to keep the Queen if
we want to keep the Queen here what else
you have
yes close very close look at this rook
here look at this look look at this
Knight these are not very well protected
this pieces this piece are called loose
pieces right when there are loose pieces
what you want to do you want to try to
make it that way to see your attacking
those loose pieces right yes haha Queen
c3 there you go now you're attacking the
Queen and still attacking the knight
okay now it's very difficult to protect
everything here so he played Queen to d6
now and here we have a position where
the Queen on the six is overworked piece
right there are few things you can do
here tea ground what's the move Queen
Queen takes e5
but he's got a bishop too don't rush
don't rush you have plenty of moves here
there are two very strong moves we have
here we need to choose between the two
moves yes Bishop c5 he wants to take
okay because the queen is overworked
it's protecting two knights right it's
protecting the both Knight so you want
to take and when it takes you take
Bishop f4 is very good too Bishop f4 is
probably very good too because you're
gonna take on B okay
that's very good as well well he played
Bishop c5 his opponent took and now
don't rush take tonight and now you're
attacking the rook and his opponent
resigned this is the end of the game but
why why he resigned why not this move do
you see the finish here because you know
what's the finish here
okay no pressure no pressure again look
at that I would look at the weak piece
the unprotected piece here and see if
you can do some kind of fork some kind
of fork our dear some kind of a fork
idea who can do the fork who can do the
fork yes you could
yeah that's a good move - that's a good
move - but how about I'd say how about
winning the full rope here
how about if you can win a full rook
here that's a big hint yeah you see it
now the full rook 25 check and take and
win the rock okay now King has to move
or King has to block something and
whatever he does you take the rook and
that's why a Fisher's opponent resigned
here okay so this is the final moment 20
moves so let's take a look from the
beginning how we get here okay so let's
see if you can remember all these moves
okay ready
okay all right the first move yes Yorick
so the name of this opening is red tea
red tea red tea okay ready
white is playing the ready system okay
now next move jittery next should be
more hands yes
now that's perfect
continue we have to play we have to get
our pieces out right which squares we
have to develop - yes give or did three
look at that the point is you got a
black hey that Bishop okay that Bishop
has to be blockaded that's the point of
this move d3 blockade c6 and that gives
our square four which piece the move d3
gives you a square for which piece now
what was the next move 92 correct and
look at this night coming to the corner
trying to go here and create some
problems
what did Fisher do to prevent that
forever is it time to play before here
is it time to play this move why a 4
yeah perfect
so what move did he play here to control
the square to control that square what
did he play here c4 now he goes b5 this
is a poor move this has moved weakens
the position now you have the fork
should be lots of hands now for the fork
remember that that's a weakening move
that b5 move is a weakening move
okay you want to move a little bit away
so you're not touching the camera the
camera moves okay okay what's the idea
fork
remember the fork here remember this
beep on push and weaken something see
the c6 square I highlighted the weakness
the weakness is the c6 square how can we
attack the c6 square here immediately
tigran 925 is a move attacking the pawn
now find a move that attacks the pawn
and something else same idea right okay
AHA much better right
because you attack the bishop - and you
want the Bishop's again what is the
value of the bishop remember the value
of the bishop people think it's equal
but it's not it's three and a quarter a
quarter let's say not three in half quad
but three and a quarter so if you can
win that Bishop that's gonna be a little
little gain for you right there
okay so he plays Queen d7 and now it's
time to play which move it's time to
play which move yes take on f5 and look
at the diagonal a bishop is so strong on
an open diagonal like that attacking
very strong diagonal now now what can
you do
very strong let's see yes
giver nice move yes
opening up the diagonal and now
threatening Bishop g5 attacking the
knight if captured then Queen takes so
he played h6 preventing that covering
the g5 square and now which piece you
want to activate here and put pressure
and again development is very important
always you have to develop your pieces
and here you have some pieces that are
not developed so you want to develop
them so which piece you want to develop
here and put some pressure yes III what
Bishop III correct and you attack that
night now if it takes Queen takes and
again lots of problems because this
bishop is very strong so it goes 96
now
yes
94 trying to trade you keep trying to
trade that knife you keep trying to
avoid that it's a little game you know
now you're attacking the pawn on f5 so
he has to go here and now now you need
to make an active move active move here
needed absolutely Queen b3 activating
the Queen and this is the moment tactic
time now the position it's already too
loose ears too loose so it's time for to
find a tactical shot here to win the
game now now you're going for the
victory here we're done with maneuvering
now we are going for a win here let's
see who remembers the tactic that starts
this idea
he can block can't block kid no longer
you know control the center after this
remember the tactic here we have so much
pressure here on d5 here he's barely
holding the position so what can we do
here to completely break through to
break through to the defense here yes
Knight takes c6 sacrificing the night he
has to take it and now follow up C takes
D attacking the Queen attacking the
knight he has to go here
and now the quiet move here needed the
quiet move not the you know you won't
take stuff but now it's quiet move here
Tigran see excellent when you see three
now attacking the Queen and attacking
that night he goes here and now we see
the example of the overworked piece by
the way a question for you if Queen was
on b6 here what can you do here look at
that pin here you have what kind of very
strong idea you have to win that night
on c5 to win the night on c5 what can
you do
which pawn before you can go to but he
goes here by daddy this is better right
so you put more on pressure here and
threaten to take so that's why he didn't
play that he went here and now we have
the Queen as being the overworked piece
it's doing too many things now it's
overworked so what we gonna do now take
the bishop takes take the knight and
block resign because if you place here
you have which move 25 check winning the
rook on b8 and Fischer's opponent resign
very nice win for Fischer okay all right
we're gonna do one study and then you
guys gonna play some practice games okay
so let's do the study now okay see if
you can you can solve this one very
famous study white to play and win
actually but believe it or not you're
done you know rook you only have a pawn
you're gonna win this game some of you
might know this one it's very famous
study okay white to play and win
why'd to play and win let's see first of
all theta well the King b7 he'll go rook
c5 and then he'll sacrifice it's gonna
be a draw pushed upon correct
he checks this is tricky this is where
it gets tricky this gets tricky a little
bit
this gets little bit tricky okay gets a
little bit of chicks where do you go
with the king that's that's the key yes
yeah king c5 the problem is now he goes
here and he puts the rogue behind it and
it's gonna be a trouble okay so we don't
want to do yet
yes
okay check
figure out again if you go there he's
gonna go down here and get behind it
check
give or B 3 B 3 stay there girl
now George check and now finally we're
down the board
we can play which move correct now it
looks like a victory it looks like a
success now because we're gonna Queen
are we gonna take the rook not so easy
he's so being tricky here very tricky
rook d4 now if you Quinn do you see the
stalemate check guess what
ste you mate okay that is a steal mate
okay draw now what is the move to win
here Isaac knows this probably very
famous position
we're gonna use an idea called George
and then he keeps checking George if you
go here he goes
check check we don't want that something
special I need from you yes aha
look look at that move perfect with the
threat of check mate with the trait of
checkmate
okay now the only way to stop it the
still mate doesn't work check I take if
you try to steam it I take there's no
stew made you go here checkmate
so now he has to go here
rook a4 and now I move after which you
win the game
yes there you go
King bee tree attacking the rook and
Roxy won
and mate that's the game okay excellent
job guys
Bravo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]